it's a whole new look for you yeah
all right johnny what's up well here we
go again you know uh i told you a few
stories about you know my life growing
up and stuff you know
i think now i'll get into my tattoos you
know i'm the type of person that uh i
really look at tattoos you know tattoos
represent a person you know with me my
tattoos represent me going through life
and my different things that happen in
my life and on i'll take you through one
at a time and tell you you know episodes
that took place why i put tattoos on my
body you know
uh the first one of course i always get
asked is my teardrop you know i've been
asked by old ladies i've been asked by
young people i've been asked by teachers
cops everything you know what does that
tattoo mean you know why is it filled in
you know why is it you know black like
that you know and i always leave them to
guess what the story's about but you
know i'll tell a story because you know
it's been a long time and you know
it's over and done with so you know i
was about
13 14 years old and um i seen all my
uncles you know my older uncles they had
tear drops you know one of them had like
three of them the other one had two the
other one had one all my uncles had tear
drops and i was wondering you know why
did they got tear drops on their face
you know what did they do you know so i
was on my youngest uncle and i was
asking him you know he had a teardrop
and i was on he had he had three of them
my youngest uncle and i told him hey i
want a teardrop he's all nah you know
you ain't ready yet you ain't ready yet
and i'm arguing with him and i'm on him
every day every day every night man
every time i see him i'm like man come
on i want that i want the teardrop i
want the teardrop and i'm real young and
he's telling me more or less nah man my
mom's gonna get mad that's my
grandmother you know she's gonna get mad
i know she won't i told him what she
want man i just want to get it i want to
get it
so he said okay well we'll see maybe
this weekend
so the week goes by i go to school and
everything and i got my heart set on
getting my tattoos so whatever he's
going to ask me to do i'm going gonna do
it because i want to earn my tattoo
well first of all he tells me okay look
you're gonna do something today that you
know a lot of people
don't do until they're 18 19 years old
you know you're going to put in some
serious work and i was like man
i don't know if i'm ready for that but
you know what i got to do well he took
me to the backyard you know i mean we
went to the spot you know i mean where
he had his things and we went over there
and he opened it he opened his this
brown suitcase as he used to have you
know it was real small it had like gold
trims on it it had a big lock on it and
he opened it up and when he opened it up
i seen that he had a few different types
of weapons in there yeah he had a 38
special over here he had a big old knife
over here yeah he had like a sword over
here and a machete over here and he's
like okay you're gonna pick one of these
and you're gonna use this tonight you're
gonna earn your teardrop
and i'm looking at the knives and you
know that young i wasn't really into
stabbing people yet i hadn't been
stabbed yet or nothing so i wasn't
really into stabbing a person you know
what i mean uh beating the person up
wasn't really nothing i already had did
that but you know they wanted me to do
something that i hadn't did they wanted
me to go do
a shooting you know what i mean i didn't
want to do driving because they don't
want to shoot the wrong person you know
i mean i don't want to shoot the wrong
person period you know i mean i i wanted
to get somebody that was you know uh
messing with my hood you know riding on
the walls coming down gang banging on us
shooting at us and at this time a lot of
shooting wasn't happening you know i
mean there wasn't a lot of gun play yet
this was like
87 88 there wasn't like drive-bys or
anything was in yet so a lot of things
was either people were getting bumper
jacked they were getting stabbed you
know you get jumped
but i wanted to hear my teardrop and he
told me okay well pick that up right
there so
i pick up the gun you know i mean i grab
it i look at it you know i mean it's
kind of heavy i remember it was kind of
heavy you know and i was like man this
thing is kind of heavy what i was
worried about was
i always seen in movies and i see when
people fire a gun you know i was in the
recoil action you know i was worried
about that because my older homie he had
went and did something and i guess he
had a big big gun and he had fired it
and he gave himself a black eye you know
me and i was like whoa you know i don't
want to i asked my uncle i don't want to
shoot this gun it hits me in my face
he's oh what are you talking about i
said it's a big gun he was no it's not
going to do that so he took me to the
backyard
and he had set up in the garage he had
set up
about six pieces of plywood and and a
mattress and he used to test fire his
guns inside that mattress
so he tells me look back up get the gun
you know me and fire it at this mattress
he made like a little you know fake like
a fake person
and he goes go ahead and fire it so we
close the doors and everything you know
put the music up and i end up firing the
fire in the gun about three four times
and i tell them i'm ready now i'm really
really scared because i'm young you know
and i'm thinking damn you know how we
gonna do this well he tells me we'll be
he goes i'll be back about seven and
eight o'clock to pick you up once it
gets dark
so i remember i'm waiting man and this
time's just going by really really slow
and i want to do this so bad but i'm
also scared because i'm real real young
you know and at that time my older
brothers and my uncles and everybody
they had already put in the work they
already earned their teardrops you know
and my grandfather used to tell me that
i was the good one because i didn't have
a teardrop on my face so he felt that i
didn't do you know the ultimate deed for
the hood so he used to always have me
right there you know next to him and i
remember when i was gonna go do this my
uncle had came at seven at night he had
brought some nicolos beers with them we
drank a few beers and i tell them hey
man what about when grandpa sees the
teardrop on my face you know he's gonna
think that you know i'm like everybody
else you know he says well you do you
want the children or not i said yeah i
want it so we get in so we get in his
car we go down the street we park in my
homies pad
and my other homie comes with i remember
it was a white car i don't know what
kind but he came in it you know i mean
you had a screwdriver inside the
ignition and [ __ ] so
at that time i didn't know it was stolen
i thought it was my homies car but i
didn't know i was in a stolen car so we
get in
and as we get in my uncle's running
through the car looking through and i'm
like man he's looking through my homies
car this is my homie's car how could he
just let him get any [ __ ] like that well
lo and behold i didn't know that it was
a g-ride so we go and then he says well
where do you want to go i said well you
know um i want to go over the bridge you
know and over the bridge is pika rivera
we're in santa fe springs and over the
bridges pico rivera so we go to pico
rivero and we get there and i remember
we're going down this street they they
got this street named villa
and it goes all the way to a culver sack
in a dead end
so i remember as we go by we see like
three dudes standing in a front yard and
i guess they got a barbecue pit going
whatever there's music whatever in we
pass them up you know what i mean they
tell me lay down in the back seat you
know they drive by they driving with me
in the back seat he tells me as soon as
i tell you to get up and fire the gun
get up and fire the gun
so at this time i'm really scared you
know i can feel my hands shaking and i'm
i'm getting i'm really scared but at the
same time i'm excited because i'm
finally gonna get a tattoo on me i had
no tattoos at all i'm finally gonna get
my first tattoo i i can't recall from 14
13 14 15. it's one of those years
but i'm really really scared man and you
know he tells me hey come on man you
ready so they go turn around and call a
second it seemed like it was going in
slow motion you know now that i think of
it you know i could put parts of it
together but we're going it's like going
in slow motion and i'm getting ready you
know i got gloves on that he gave me you
know i got a beanie real low and i never
wear a beanie i only wear a beating when
i go out at night you know i do my do my
thing
so i gotta be on real low you know i
mean no mass nothing
and uh
so we pull up when we pull up to this to
this place we're at
there's a car that's parked right in
front of us
and what my homie does is he gets right
on the car like right at the tailgate of
the car and he tells me there's a guy in
the white shirt get the guy in the white
shirt there's a guy i remember when i
when i look up i peek over the window
think where the windows that i peek up
and i look and i see a guy in a white
shirt and he's oh he's lighting
something i don't know if it's a joint
or a dipper but i remember he's lighting
something
and he goes going that's the guy that's
the guy so i go over the windowsill i
remember i go to the windowsill and
i think i see twice
and i miss the dude completely i miss
him completely i mean i i don't know
what it was i mean i pointed the gun and
everything but it missed him completely
i remember the dude drops whatever he
had to see whatever and
he stood there for a minute and then he
turned to run and when he turned the run
they're telling me fire fire so
again i go and i fire again the next
thing i know i see dude fall down i
don't know if i hit him i don't know if
he fell because he tripped over
something but i remember dude falls down
and i get back in the seat now i'm
sweating you know and i feel myself like
like i'm young so i'm scared and i
remember i don't want to cry but
it's coming i could feel that come
inside you know because i'm really
really scared because we're already
taking off and my homies driving like a
maniac you know to get back to the hood
and we'll go give me that give me that
give me that and i don't want to give it
up i'm like nope i ain't giving it up i
didn't give it up because i remember a
story that i heard
if you ever do something with someone or
something don't ever give that thing up
to anybody keep it yourself get rid of
it yourself don't put in nobody else's
hand because they can trace things back
to you so i don't want to give this up i
don't want to give this up i remember we
get to my backyard we get to the side of
my backyard and i just throw it over the
fence you know out the window i throw it
over the fence and it goes inside the
yard at that time the cops pulled up
boom the cops got us right there they
pulled up boom they don't got us for
what happened down the street but they
got us there and they're asking what are
we doing here you know what's going on
and i remember my aunt
is in the backyard and she had just got
high and smoked some pcp
and the cops were telling her
to get whatever was thrown over the
fence
and she's looking and she's trying to
see who it is and my uncle is trying to
tell her no it's his wifey shout and
tell her no but she's so high that she's
looking for whatever got thrown over the
gate
so as she's looking for it i kind of
like stepped two feet away from the cup
and i tell her no don't get it don't get
if she sees me tell her no so she stops
and she don't get it
so they get us i remember we got caught
with some pcp
so
they tell us well whose juice is it you
know what i mean and they're looking at
me i'm real young what happens is they
go to everybody and they start smelling
you know like their hands and their and
you know their bodies see if they smell
like juice i guess my homie that was
driving he was one with the juice so
they ended up taking him to jail they
let me and my uncle go so once me and my
uncle go okay i tell my uncle okay i
want my teardrop so i remember he calls
my other uncle my other uncle comes in
the room he comes with all his equipment
you know he comes with his equipment all
his [ __ ] his ink and everything and uh
i'm thinking oh man this is gonna hurt
really bad you know but he's all oh what
do you want it at and i'm like what i
wanted that what do you mean he's like
you know what side do you want it at
you know i'm like well what do you mean
what side well he said well everybody
gets it on the left side you know he
goes but
we my older homies i remember they from
my father they had their right ear
pierced and back then a right ear
pierced used to mean that you were
homosexual that you were gay but my
homies wanted to do something different
so they had all pierced their right ear
so i said you know what i want my
children up on the right side you know
me so he says on the right side i said
yeah i'm not i'm not going to get my
right ear pierced but i can get the
tattoo on the right side he goes well
that's the wrong side i said well to me
it's going to be the right side because
you know i like to keep my homies always
just have to keep things
in the hood that represented something
that kept the hood going you know how
could you put it they used to keep
things uh
really really
really really tight in the hood you know
there's certain things we did and we
kept it through generations generations
so i remember i had got my teardrop and
i had got it
the next morning i woke up
you mean and when i woke up i went to
rub my face and i rubbed my eyes and i
remember i rubbed the scab off
and what happened was i rubbed the
middle of it off so it was it was a
teardrop but it had a clear part in the
middle you know i had rubbed it off the
ink didn't stay in so now i had to tear
drop on my face with the middle missing
so i had to walk around like about
two months with
i'm getting a ballpoint pen and filling
in my teardrop so a lot of people used
to think it was fake you know what i
mean i remember i used to feel it and
every every time i went out i used to
get the little ballpoint pen the blue
one and i'd fill in my teardrop well as
soon as i got my teardrop you know uh i
had stated before all my family cried
except my grandmother and my home used
to trip because i was young i was 14
years old you know i mean i had a
teardrop on my face and i remember
people used to ask me you know what does
that tear drop represent you know and i
was young i didn't want to say nothing
and they used to say does that mean you
lost somebody or does it it hadn't meant
that i did time because i was only 14
years old so they could eliminate that
but i remember this one old lady
i remember i was walking down the street
nice to see this old lady all the time
you know and i always used to pass her i
was just a passer well you know once i
got that teardrop on my face i noticed
that old that old lady that i used to
pass every morning would cross the
street when i would come down it and she
barely had started doing this so i was
wondering why is this old lady all of a
sudden crossing the street i mean did
she hear something bad about me you know
because i used to clean her yard and do
stuff like that you know and she used to
paint me so one day i went to her house
because she used to sell sodas and juice
and [ __ ] out of her house
i went to buy a soda and she acted kind
of funny with me and i had to ask her i
was like excuse me you know ma'am did i
do something wrong you know because i
noticed that when i walk down the street
you cross the street now before you used
to stay there and i used to pass by and
it was nothing she said well to be
typically honest with you you know
i see that you got a new tattoo you know
i really didn't notice that
a tattoo on your face is noticed by a
lot of people me when i look in the
mirror now today or before after i got
it i didn't see it i didn't see the
tattoo you know the tattoo wasn't there
but i remember you know a lot of people
just stare at me and i see their eyes
look at me and then look at my teardrop
and they look back at me and then their
whole demeanor would change and i used
to wonder why would their demeanor
change well
later in time i found out that a tattoo
on your face a teardrop filled in means
that
you had did the ultimate sacrifice and
took somebody's life you know and i
you know when people used to look at me
back in the day and i've had detergents
on my face all my life where people used
to look at me really really bad and i
used to say wait up you know i to tell
people after you know when i get to know
myself you got to get to know me just
don't look at me and see the teardrop on
my face and just stereotype me as a bad
person because i had that problem a lot
with the ways to look at people to drop
on my face very young people used to
look at me and they used to tell me
after they met me they used to tell me
man when i first seen you
i didn't want you to kick it in my house
i didn't want you to come around i
didn't want to be around you because you
look like the type of person that would
start a lot of [ __ ]
and i was like that wasn't the person i
was you know they had to get to know me
before
you know they can judge me and they used
to judge me on my teardrop a lot so you
know once i got my teardrop i wanted my
next tattoos and my next tattoos of
course i wanted to did you did you kill
that guy
i mean to tell you the truth
i can't say today if i did or i didn't
but the whole thing about it was i seen
him fall
i no longer seen dude around anymore he
wasn't around anymore my older homies
used to talk about it but they used to
keep the stuff in between them you know
it never came back to me and said hey
you actually
smoke dude or you actually put him down
in the dirt but i got my teardrop and
they filled it in that's the important
thing you know that's incredible and
they filled it in and when they filled
it in
that represented to me that i did
something that a lot of my homies my age
had and did so when i had my teardrop i
wanted to earn my frogs and i knew that
to get a frog on our body the way we did
in my hood was you had to earn that frog
you know you had to earn it you couldn't
just put a frog on your body because if
you put a frog on your body and you
didn't earn it my homies would deal with
your ass regardless of who you were you
know i mean and there was my homies
walking around with two frogs one frog
you know i just wanted a frog on me you
know what i mean and i want it and i
used to think where am i going to get it
first i was going to get it on my neck
real big and i was like nah i don't want
to get it on my neck you know i'll get
it somewhere so i went to my body and
decided all right well this is the arm i
use the most oh i'll get it on my elbow
and this was the first frog that i
actually earned
i was like
about maybe 15 and a half years old i
had just got out of camp
and my homies my little homie picked up
a tattoo gun he was young he was about
14 years old and he was tattooing on
everybody his name was chino he was
really really good you know and he was
real young i'm talking about he was 14
years old but he was he was asian so he
was real small but he used to get down
on the tattoos and i remember i told him
hey man i want a frog he's like well you
know did you already go and do your
thing i said i'm gonna come back next
week and i want my frog
so i wanna see how am i gonna earn my
frog what's gonna happen you know what i
mean
so i went to my backyard and i said you
know what
i already used a weapon now i want to
make something where i can actually beat
somebody that's with it real real good
so what i did was i went to my backyard
and i found a leg to a table to a table
now this leg was it was an old table
so this a leg was really really thick so
what i did with it was i got a gang of
nails
and i hammered the nails through the
wood and they stuck out on the other
side the sharp sharp end so what i did
was i stuck nails all through it all
through it and then what i did was i
shellacked it and then i burnt it with a
torch you know i mean to make sure the
nails would stay sturdy and there's a
telephone pole in my backyard
and i practiced on hitting it i was like
okay this is what i'm going to use to
earn my frogs
so what happened was
they were having a party in my hood
and i was on my uncles again you know i
was on them i was on them i want to earn
my frog when i earned my frog
well lo and behold i earned my frog
without me even knowing that i earned it
you know we went to a party
the [ __ ] jumped off there was like five
brothers that were from another hood on
the other side of us but there were five
brothers and don't get me wrong these
five brothers their last name began with
a you know i say no names you protect
the innocent his last their last name
began with an a they know who they are
there's like five brothers man and these
dudes right here were no [ __ ] joke
and they were like a trip because they
were the sizes like big all the way down
to the little one and the little one was
the most [ __ ] of them all he was the
one that started all this [ __ ] he's the
one that did the most damage but he was
the little brother this is the one we
wanted all the time i remember wearing a
party and we were really [ __ ] young
and we were drinking
we were drinking and drinking i was
getting drunk i was already you know
spinning a little bit and i remember i
see these two dudes walk in and these
[ __ ] dudes man they were healthy man
they were like they were already in
their 30s so they had already been to
the joint they were like monsters man
they were big you know
so i'm looking at them and i'm
recognizing these fools and i'm saying
damn because these brothers all look
alike and i'm saying what do i know
these [ __ ] faces at and i'm looking
i'm looking at them and then i see my
homie says oh that's a [ __ ]
name he says the last name and right
there he kicks in boom
i'm like oh [ __ ] so i go to the back of
the house where i put my big ass [ __ ]
log at and i grabbed it i pulled it out
and i remember it
one of those big old bug dudes had one
of my homies by the shirt and he was
just pounding on my homie man i remember
he was hitting my homie so hard that you
can hear it man and it sounded like
bones were cracking but this dude was
just so big that he he broke my homies
nose he broke his cheekbone by the time
i got to him i remember i had this
[ __ ] wooden thing man
and i swung this [ __ ] so hard that i
remember when i hit this dude you know
have you ever got a bat and you hit a
metal pole and it goes
you know you get that zing feeling well
that's what i got when i hit this dude
in back of his head with this [ __ ]
stick now i don't know if any nails went
in his head or anything but i remember i
hit this dude with everything i had and
when i [ __ ] hit him he just hit the
ground boom i remember when he hit the
ground like a few minutes later because
i'm swinging this thing at everybody you
know i mean i don't care who's in my way
whether i almost hit my brother i almost
hit my cousin that was there i'm
swinging it wild after i hit this dude
i'm swinging it wild because they're
trying to take it from me the dude was
there with like three of his brothers
three his brothers were trying to take
it from me but they weren't getting
close because i was swinging it wild
and i remember that hit that i hit him
it like gave me a shock through my body
like
it like it shook and i was like what the
[ __ ] was that i don't know what it was
if i hit his skull and from the wood
hitting the bone it made a certain
[ __ ] jolt in my body and i remember
after i hit dude after i swung it like
about 10 more times
i remember one of the brothers man he
[ __ ] reached to grab me and i
remember his fingers
went along my face scratched my nose and
scratched my chin with one of his nails
he went to grab my face when i had that
pole he didn't give a [ __ ] he went to
grab my face and i remember his hand
just sliding across my face you know and
i don't forget that because i tell
myself man if that dude would have
[ __ ] been able to grab me he would
have probably just broke my [ __ ] neck
because he was so [ __ ] big you know
what i mean and i felt his hand just you
know now i think about it i remember man
he left a little cut on my little skull
in my nose and i remember this dude was
so big
then when he [ __ ] went to grab me
push me at the same time and i fell to
the ground when i fall to the ground
i see these two dudes on one of my
homies and they're doing a number on
them and they're doing a number on them
so bad so but then my cousin he's from
another hood but he kicks it with us
he comes i see him throw a karate kick
and his [ __ ] he kicks these dudes and
then
boom you know the cops are here boom so
we all jump balls we split so as i'm
running down the street my older homie's
running with me and he's like man oh you
did that you did that little homie you
know i mean you did that little homie
when i haven't put a frog on you and put
a frog on you and i'm like
[ __ ] what did i just do you know i mean
i didn't realize that when i hit this
[ __ ] dude i knocked him out cold
he was in a coma for like five days you
know i mean his his mom came to my
grandmother's house and was complaining
they had blamed my my youngest uncle for
it they didn't blame me for it they
blamed my youngest uncle he did go to
prison for that but i'm the one who had
did it my uncle went to prison for it
and uh you know
as my grandmother you know she she she
told me you know what it happened they
were blaming my uncle you know i told my
grandmother the truth i said look we're
at a party this is what happened i got
the stick in the backyard you know i
mean this is what i built i told her
exactly what it's meant right now you
know that i built it and everything and
i hit that dude boom there came my frog
i remember we were kicking it they tell
me hey come inside at one of the spots
in my hood i go in there my little
homie's in there he got the neato
already he's all you're ready you're
ready there's a few patterns of frogs
and i remember i'm looking through them
and i go to the poison dart frog it's
from africa that's this one it's the one
where you know the the people in africa
get their darts and they rub it on the
skins of the frogs and then when they
shoot a monkey or whatever they got to
shoot it actually paralyzes them and
sends them you know it paralyzes the
animal it falls and it can't run or
nothing it's just instantly paralyzed
with you know the frog's skin so i
wanted that one you know so i end up
getting this one
i ended up getting this one that was the
first frog i got so then i have one frog
and then i seen my homies with two or
three and i was like man these dudes are
just a little bit older than me you know
what i mean [ __ ] that i want another one
so now i want to earn two frogs at one
time and i'm like man that's gonna be
kind of hard but i'm gonna try it you
know so i remember i'm thinking okay how
can i
get two guys in in one place at the same
time and hurt them both well i used to
know this girl that i used to go to
school with you know i mean and you know
through the years i had i explained
before that i had been set up a lot of
times but i also set up a lot of foods
with a lot of women because that was my
thing you know my youngest uncle had
told me
the best way to be good in the hood and
be able to get at your enemies is to be
with their home girls because once you
be with their home girls and you lay
down with them they're going to give you
vital information that they wouldn't
give anybody else so sure enough i laid
down with one of their homegirls and
after i was being with her a while told
her i loved her and everything when i
didn't you know what i mean i just told
her that to suck her up you know and
every time i go home i'll ask my uncle
okay i'll tell him what i did how much
time i spent with her or anything he
would tell me okay do this next time do
this next time and it was working so i
got it to the point where
she actually invited them over to her
house
and i was already gonna be in there
waiting
now what i had was
i had this pipe that we made into a zip
gun okay it's a zip gun a zip code is
made out of two pipes
with a 12 gauge shell inside and you
bang it from the back it got the nail
cemented in
and it's two poles that slide together
and when they slide short
it actually shoots the 12 gauge shot out
of it and it's only about this big you
wrap them in electrical tape because if
you do it with no electrical tape it'll
burn the [ __ ] out of your hands once it
fires it should get so hot you'll have
to drop it and you don't want to drop it
so i got it my uncle had made one and
this was a little short one like this he
hadn't made it real good it
it screwed onto the back had the cement
in there with the little nail i already
tested it a few times so i'm like okay
one of the dudes i'm gonna hate with
this [ __ ] and then the other dudes i'm
hit with a pipe but it happened the
opposite way what happened was she
called him to her house i'm in the
backyard hiding behind a tree she gets
into the backyard they sit down with her
on some lounge chairs she had in her
backyard by her deck she had like a deck
and then a patio and she had him right
there in the patio
so i walked her from behind and instead
of going first with the shanghai nah i
went i hit the first guy right on the
side of the neck with i hit it
boom as soon as i hit him he [ __ ]
took off running he took off running
jumped the gate left his homie so i was
home he's like hey man hey man we gotta
who are you you know he's asking why am
i [ __ ] you recognize me you know
who i am you know he knew who i was but
he's so scared that he's like amen amen
so he's trying to get into the house
and i fire that thing when i fire that
thing
i thought i didn't hit him because he
was going inside the door i seen his
clothes you know i seen his shirt like
flat to the side but i didn't know that
the bird shot had sprayed out it wasn't
a slug it was a bird shot so when it
sprayed it sprayed him through the door
through the crack of the door it got his
skin and it blew his shirt so he had
fell inside there i didn't know i
thought he had took off running she was
so scared that she had told me just
leave just leave he's lying in the
garage you know he's lying to god he's
bleeding to death she lied to me so i
would get out of there we were young but
i shot this dude now when i went back to
the hood
i guess this broad had talked to one of
my little home girls they were friends i
don't know how were enemies but anyways
they're friends she tells my little
homegirl what's up my homegirl tells my
homies my older homies get find out
they call me to the park they're like
hey
did you go over here the other day and
move
ah
look you don't need to lie to us we're
asking you because of the fact that
homie's gonna be here this weekend he's
gonna tack on some people do you want to
get you know another tattoo and i said
yeah i want to get another tattoo he
said well what do you want i said i want
my two frogs he said okay well what
happened last weekend
two guys got assaulted in
in this man's backyard what happened was
the ladies the girl's dad came home and
he was like paisa he was like mexican
dude the cops came around and [ __ ] and
they talked to him and he pumped it out
of his daughter to get the information
he gave the cops the information
but
they it was a trip because now they
didn't blame me they blame my cousin one
that's a year older than me for some
reason i used to do [ __ ] and these fools
used to get blamed i wouldn't they
wouldn't say it wasn't them and i
wouldn't say it was me but they always
used to get blamed so now they're
blaming my older cousin and i'm kicking
back in the living room listening to my
grandfather and he [ __ ] got the steak
and he's whooping my cousin with it
right
and my cousin's looking at me like
[ __ ] i'm not gonna say nothing
but he's whipping my cousin with it and
i remember i'm the one that did what my
grandfather was whipping my cousin's ass
for because you know dad's you know the
adults like the the parents of people
used to come to the house and complain a
lot you know about what we were doing i
mean we made the city bus stop coming
through you don't mean that we we was
that bad you know when the city bus came
through we'd bomb it with bricks you
know we didn't figure old ladies were
riding it you know regular citizens we
used to just see these dudes in the back
with the little windows open flipping us
out throwing their hood so we'd wait
till the bus comes in we'll break it
we made the city bus stop coming through
you know the city called my grandmother
said the bus is no longer going to run
by your house because of what your gran
your grandchildren are doing so she got
at us and she told us hey that's it
they're going to stop the city bus from
coming through if one more thing happens
what happens my little brother gets out
of ya here comes the bus none of us pick
up a brick who picks up a break he does
he picks up a brick throws it boom hits
dude inside the head through the window
this bus stops coming by so you know he
my cousin's getting his ass whooped for
what happened in the weekend when that
man came complaining then he's getting
his ass whooped because they think he's
the one that threw a break at the bus he
got the bus stop coming through so he's
getting his ass quote for both of those
i'm kicking back he gets his ass work we
go the backyard he ends up trying to
whip my ass but my uncle gets on his ass
because
i'm going to get my tattoo you know what
i mean and my older cousin you know he's
my main man right he's my main ace deuce
in the hole you know me and him are
really really tight now you know we're
like two in the family that we don't we
don't give a [ __ ] what anybody else says
it's what me and him say you know and i
remember he was getting that ass
whooping after he got in trouble with my
ass and i told him hey man i didn't i
didn't say anything that you or anybody
who goes well i'm always getting blamed
for [ __ ] you do i said i don't know i
don't know if they mistake me for you
but
all through my life they would blame my
cousin for the [ __ ] i would do and
sometimes i would have to correct the
record and say wait wait a minute he
didn't do that [ __ ] i did that [ __ ] you
know i mean i thought i was doing
something good when i was really doing
something bad but i felt like [ __ ] this
i'm the one putting in work they gave me
this [ __ ] the credit you know
what i mean and i'm the [ __ ]
doing all the [ __ ] dirt and i was
getting mad you know so they had blamed
him for that i went to the party boom
they showed me the patterns what do you
want i had picked
my two frogs i wanted one frog
to be watching out for the other frog
you know this is the frog he's putting
it work this is the guy that's watching
out for him you know what i mean and i
seen these on a cup you know they had a
cup in a magazine and i told my homie i
want these two frogs and my homie just
be able to look at it and go so he gave
me my two frogs when he gave my two
frogs now i had one and i had two and i
said okay well
i didn't want to stop there i wanted to
get at least seven on my body
i know i got one two three
four five
six seven yeah i got seven i got seven
and then i got
uh
what do you call it um
what is it called a you know as from a
tadpole all the way up to to a frog and
then the bones you know evolution i got
evolution running down my spine and
their tadpoles get bigger and bigger you
know one tadpole than the up with two
legs then four legs then a tap a frog
with a tail and then a frog and then
bones
all the way down my spine you know and
i'll get into that one right now how i
earned that one but i wanted some more
frogs and i remember i wanted two on my
shoulders i wanted to sit on my
shoulders i'm a gemini so i wanted two
frogs
that were twins but you had to make just
a little little difference so what i did
was i put a dot a black dot inside one
of them so you know twins are always
identical but something's always
different so i wanted to earn these how
i earned these was at school i didn't
give a [ __ ] i went and
with the mom's birth child and i shot at
the school this is not a big school not
a public school but a continuation
school where when you got out of hawaii
or you got a camp they send you to this
school and it's only two classrooms well
these foods it's in my hood and these
foods were kept gangbanging gangbanging
i finally said take me over there my
homie took venus toyota truck i remember
it was it was it wasn't even a shotgun
it was another zip gun we had made it
was all wrapped in black tape and i
remember when i got off the passenger
side to shoot at the guys i dropped one
of the [ __ ] pieces of the pipe and
the [ __ ] [ __ ] rolled under the truck
lucky my homie had a big truck and it
was lifted
i went under the truck and grabbed it
pulled it back out these fools didn't
run they were still right there [ __ ] you
you know me they were little reason to
[ __ ] you so i came around the truck and
i said man [ __ ] you
boom man i remember that [ __ ] like a big
old [ __ ] i don't know where the
[ __ ] smoke but like a big cloud of
smoke came out you mean people were
screaming and lit girls were screaming
dudes were running everywhere my mom was
like getting the truck in the truck i'm
like [ __ ] that give me another give me
another [ __ ] shower he's like get in
the truck it's broad day it's like it's
like two in the afternoon broad daylight
keenan is shot he finally throws me
another shot i get it put in
boom i don't even think anybody's there
but i'm like [ __ ] this boom i shot at
the school at the front two two glass
doors boom i missed the whole [ __ ] hit
the side of the wall how i found that
afterwards when i went to school a year
later i remember i shot at this school
so i wanted to look to see where i had
hit
and i only found one spot so as the time
went by oh yeah you heard somebody got
shot over here by the school but you
know that's bird spray on his back and i
was like so then my homies caught it
they put it together and they were like
okay
next week and they said they used to do
it every every other week and they would
have a party or tattoo party so they
called me they're like hey
were you the one that and i was to deny
it nah it wasn't me you're lying tell us
what happened homie said he took you
over there you know my homies i wish i
told my homies when they used to drive
me places first of all i used to put a
gun out on them that was number one i
put a gun out of town you're taking me
and you take me you're gonna take me you
know that that because a lot of my homes
would be like no i'm not taking them
because they didn't want to go do this
deed that i wanted to pull and they knew
once i got a little bit of tipsy and i
had a gun we're gonna go [ __ ] gun
somebody down and you were gonna take me
i've had a lot of my homies tell me now
i'm taking you
you're taking me [ __ ] you know
what they'd be like johnny why you gotta
do it get in the car you know what i'd
have to practically kidnap my homie just
to take me somewhere and when i went i
went from the morning all the way to the
night non-stop all the way through until
i found someone i found somebody through
the middle of the day that's the end of
it but one time i went from 11 in the
morning all the way to 11 at night and i
finally caught somebody at 11 at night
it was the last week we were going
through so you know i used to pull guns
out of my homies and threaten them you
know in the park like in the [ __ ] car
and they've been like why are you doing
this why just get in the [ __ ] car
we'll get in the car and then i'll
explain to him look man you know i mean
i need somebody to take me you're the
one with the car you know i'm not gonna
go steal my [ __ ] stolen crying i've
got time for all that i gotta handle
some business it's serious let's go and
my homies used to take me even though it
was under distressed i used to make them
take me and a lot of them were mad at me
through the years because of that you
know allow me to say why you to threaten
me to take you places and i said tell me
because you [ __ ] don't want to
take nobody you're the one with the car
man i'm not going to [ __ ] ride a bike
and go from the shoot at somebody and
get caught down the street you got a car
we got time to get away there was a
couple of my homies that had cars and
they were down for it but a lot of my
homies had nice cars and they felt they
were just going to kick it in the hood
look good and be there for the girls no
what about putting in the work what
about representing the hood you know had
a lot of homies that didn't want to do
that so i used to have to force them to
do it and i was known to pull guns out
on my own homies and make them take me
well to earn my tour up here i made my
homie take me we were in the park i
remember we were sitting there had a
bottle of vodka and i was sipping it
and the park you know it's open and
there's a lot of homies sticking around
and i got me a little you know i got me
only a little 25 and then i'm kicking it
and i'm like i look at my homie i tell
me no you got your car right here
oh no johnny come on you got you got
your car right here though and i'm
already feeling a little faded i just
pulled my gun out what's up [ __ ]
you're gonna take me i remember my home
girl's like why you always do that
johnny why are you like oh [ __ ] a [ __ ]
you know before i make you take me and
she said she shut up real quick cause
she had a car too and she know i'll make
her take me so anyways my homie took me
i'm glad my homie took me because
what we had did was we went found some
food i lit them up and after i did that
deed my homie that was driving the car
he became totally someone totally
different
from a lame and a lot that didn't even
want to put in work they didn't even
want a gang bang he became to a
full-pledged
gang bang bank robber he did a gang of
time you know i mean he's known in my
hood after i did that deed with him it
just took that little push
to set his heart to set his heart on
fire that's that's what i say i set his
heart on fire with just a little push i
just wanted to show him
this is how you do it you know everybody
says they could do it this way let me
show you how it's done and when i showed
my homie you know
through the years
it it it it showed in him i've seen in
him a dramatic change you know because
he used to get punked by my homies they
used to take his car they used to take
his bud take his drugs
after i did that with him they weren't
touching him you know now he had a strap
on him all the time he'd wanted to take
people to go put in work he'd go by
himself
park his car
light somebody up get back in his car
and take off so you know i was kind of
glad that i gave my homie that push now
that i'm a little bit older and i think
about it
uh maybe that was a little wrong of me
due to the fact that i changed his life
dramatically like you know he did
[ __ ] seven years and he did nine
years you know and before he wasn't even
going to go to going to jail he had a
wife and kids now he's on his third wife
who gets like 15 kids you know he got a
gang of felonies you know and always
when i look at him i i feel bad a little
bit but then at the same time i feel
good because my homie grew
up grew into something that he wasn't
going to grow into in the beginning if i
wouldn't have took them and i took them
under distress i saved the stress
because they went under distress they
didn't want to go
so i ended up getting my shoulder frogs
but i got my shoulder frogs in jail you
know i got them they hooked them up you
know i mean and i was saying okay i got
all these i wanted one more and i was
like man i'm already
i was already like 30 something years
old and i was like man that's kind of
old to me
out there doing the deed man 31 you know
but then i seen my homie he was like 42
[ __ ] big old pants pendleton
[ __ ] a hair net all tacked up still
gang member and he's like 42 years old
he's already a grandfather that fool's
still getting banged out and i'm like
okay that gave me the that gave me the
right feeling to
earn my last frog i don't know that's
probably wanted on my side real big you
know what i mean and i wanted to earn it
right and i remember having already
earned one
firing a gun i had already earned
another one
hitting my [ __ ] with but now i wanted
to earn one by
poking somebody letting the air out of
them you know and i wasn't gonna hurt
him bad i didn't look to go
take anybody's life i just wanted to
step somebody to see how it actually
felt because i just see my homies used
to come oh man i stabbed that fool like
15 times oh man you should have seen him
more and i'm listening to it like wow
you know how could somebody's uh 15
times on somebody you know
but once
i was going to earn the side one
i had got stabbed first when they
stabbed me
that clicked the light on in my head
where [ __ ] that if they're gonna stab me
i'ma stab everybody else so that's what
i did once they stabbed me when i healed
up i went got me the nicest buck knife i
could find
sharpen that [ __ ] so sharp like cut
hair cut that [ __ ] was so sharp i
grabbed it and i said okay now it's time
boom i took it put it in my back pocket
boom we went to uptown whittier we went
to the uh
whittier festival the ritter festival
they got a [ __ ] carnival and [ __ ]
that's going on you know and we're
rolling up there like man we're like
[ __ ] 30 deep there's like 30 of us
were rolling through the street i
remember and man the cops were coming
and they would just turn around go the
other way and i was like what the [ __ ]
why didn't these cops pulling us over
you know i guess because there was so
many of us they had to group up get
enough cops to come and get us so we're
walking through this festival and i
remember i see the festival kind of
upward you know we are i already got
shot at like about five minutes before
by some foods i thought were my homies i
thought they were my homies coming out
because there was so many of us i
thought my homies were coming out the
alley it was my enemies and i'm over
here what's up homies come on dog what's
up until we got close and i said what
the [ __ ] that don't look like none of my
homies do pull out a cannon
let me have it he missed me but he let
me have it he unloaded that big ass
cannon i remember the fire was coming
out that [ __ ] and i was trying to zig
zagging and run i have ping pong you
know i see mother homie fall i thought
he got hit you know in the chest because
the way he fell but wasn't that he just
jumped back because the dude was firing
well after dudes ran and [ __ ] that's
when the cops came and then turned
around and left we get up to the
festival we're kicking it and i'm
looking around i'm looking around
looking boom i spot this food man i spot
this food that i've been wanting to get
for a long ass time and i say here it is
here's the [ __ ] i'ma get all i
did was i circled around one of the
little [ __ ] places that sell hot dogs
and [ __ ] circle around there talk to
this little this broad that i know from
school hey what's up i talk to her real
quick i'm watching this for watching he
gets in line to ride that big old
[ __ ]
ferris wheel and i say [ __ ] it i'm just
going to run minus
but i didn't even have to do that all of
a sudden [ __ ] kicked off over here with
my homies and another hood they started
getting busy security all started
running towards them dude was over here
looking see what's going on kept up from
behind a man
i just gave him one good one
that's all it took too
i don't think dude died i know he fell
on the floor i know he was bleeding like
a [ __ ] because one of the
security guards tried to grab me by my
shirt once once i stabbed him i guess
once i stabbed him
the security guard seen it i backed up
to look to see if i'd have to stab him
again [ __ ] no he was on the ground
already holding his side a security
guard came up i remember he was a big
tall black dude and he [ __ ]
grabbed my [ __ ] caller like and i
[ __ ] wow pulled up that big ass buck
knife wow nephew let go like hey and i
said [ __ ] get off me you know i
was going to stab him too because i just
stopped doing i got to get away i
remember i ran from uptown
all the way to my hood and that's like a
three mile run and i didn't stop i
didn't stop one time my chest was
certain i couldn't breathe i had to lay
down like a couple of times when the
cops came by because it was cops going
to i lay down in a flower bed for like
15 minutes you know with just a little
brick flower bed you barely lay in there
where the cops can't see you i laid in
one of those i hid in the bush i hid in
the tree all the way home but i didn't
stop running when i got home i said okay
this is it now i thought about it it's
okay this is my last frog on my urn
and i got it i put it on my skin and it
was all good you know what i mean and
you know uh people that know my hood and
they they know our traditions how we do
it you know guys from other hoods that
do it similar they would ask me you know
where i'm from and stuff and then they'd
be like hey you got any frogs in your
body
and i tell them yeah oh how many guys
and i'll tell them they're like wow all
right yeah i know you're homie so and so
now they would wrap to me in a different
fashion the same as my homies from the
hood not all my homies got frogs on them
but a lot of my homies that got frogs in
them are all respected because in our
hood you had to earn the frog you know
what i'm saying and
i earned them all and i remember that
one i go back to is my teardrop i
remember when i was
35 years old i wanted to take it off my
face i was tired of people looking at me
stereotyping me as a bad person people
asking me what does that tear drop me
did you kill somebody you know i was
tired did you go to prison i was tired
of people
asking me those questions so i went to
the uh
the place where they removed tattoos and
i went made my appointments and
everything they told me how long it
would take it was close to my eyes so
they were gonna have to do you know
certain procedure to take it out you
know what i mean and i was like okay so
yeah i'd come back like five times i
remember i was about to go the next day
i had my appointment
and um
my i called my older daughter and i'm
like hey what's going on joe she's like
what's up dad i go hey i'm going to go
tomorrow and and go to the tattoo place
where they remove tattoos she's like
what are you talking about i'm like yeah
i'm going to take the tattoo off my face
the teardrop she's like why dad
if you take it off your face that's not
gonna beat you anymore you're gonna be
somebody else and i was like
what do you mean she's like yeah dad i
mean that's how i know you you know
i know that's you even if i see you from
a distance i see the teardrop on your
face i know that's you if you have a
mask on i can know that's you because i
see the trigger up on your face that's
how i know you dad
i don't know you any other way
and when she told me that i was like
but don't you want me to take the
trigger about my face she said no
don't take it off your face if you take
it off your face you're going to be
somebody else
that's a part of your life that's part
of you that that's your whole setup
right there that's what makes you look
the way you look you know keep it like
that
and i hug the phone and i thought about
it and i said damn my little girl
doesn't want me to ruin my teardrop what
the hell i thought she would tell me
yeah dad take it off your face nope she
want me to remove it the next day my
other little girl got up and she's like
dad will you take me to school today we
put your glasses on your jersey shirt
you know i was wondering why would she
want me to dress like that well my
little girl knew me as that she was six
years old but she wanted to show her
little friends
that her daddy
looks like this that her daddy is a gang
member that her daddy's been in prison
that her daddy is a troll that her daddy
sells drugs you know this is what my
little girl is telling her friends at
six years old seven years old telling
these little kids i don't know this
until i found out after one of the
little kids told me you know what i mean
you a gang and you're in a gang and i
was like huh
who told you that he's like johnny told
me and i like look at my girl what else
did she tell you and he told me
everything you know and then i took her
home and i told her why baby what just
because i want to show you i want to
show you that you're my dad you know and
that you know i want you to wear this
and wear that so she wanted me a dress a
certain way
which
really i haven't even took out of myself
you know my pants are still begging my
shirts are still big that's like the
hardest thing to get rid of is my attire
you know i could try to change it a
little bit maybe with some glasses and a
hat but
my attire i have to feel loose fitting
you know what i'm saying it has to go
with how i feel it's just something
that's embedded in me and like the dude
brings me a pair of pants that are 36 30
that's my waist
i won't dare put them on
38 36 38 i won't dare put them on
because they actually feel tight on me
they're not tight don't get me wrong now
mark they're not tight pants it's just
that i feel more comfortable with
something baggier i i feel more relaxed
you know me i feel more in me you know
when i put something on that's tight or
some shoes that look kind of funny i
feel awkward and i asked myself a lot
you know
why do i feel awkward why do i feel this
way you know am i supposed to be a
certain way in a certain way only you
know i went back and i thought about the
times that i spoke
you know to you and
i always go back to
i was not given the chance to be who i
wanted to be
i was set in motion
from being born all the way to be who i
became
and they and my family
just set me
you know
to go this way even though it was the
wrong way prison and all that they sent
me to go this way and that was set ever
since i was a little boy it wasn't it
wasn't given to me and saying okay you
got the option go to college graduate
high school get a family you know that
wasn't offered to me like that if there
was nothing wrong it was offered one
thing boom this is who you are this is
you're gonna be you're gonna follow in
the footsteps that your family has
fallen so i wasn't given the opportunity
to
be someone
who i someone successful somebody who i
actually wanted to be i i i was tooken
from that i was not given that a lot of
people you know i tell a lot of people
on times when they speak to me they stop
me on the street i tell them you know
look at me as me you know the person i
the person i tell you i am this is
somebody i became somebody who they set
me in motion to be this person i wasn't
given an option and a choice to become
a lawyer or or become a police officer
or become a school teacher i wasn't
given that option the option wasn't put
there yeah i was in school but i was
known to be in school and to get kicked
out by seventh grade and now go back to
the 10th grade and then get kicked out
again and then not go back and get a ged
in prison that's what i was set up to be
you know that's why a lot of people when
they
go through these
you know films that you put on there a
lot of them stop me and tell me on the
street you know they like the way i
speak about it because all i'm appear
speaking is the truth like i say no
names or i say anything but i talk a lot
about me because
i like to let the people know that if
you if you're given that option to go a
certain way and you want that go get it
don't let no one dictate and portray
what you're doing because i was set in
motion from ever since i was a little
boy to be this person and this person i
become
a lot of me don't like him but at times
i lock him up and put him away and i
don't and people knock for him to come
out and people ask for him and he wants
to come out but i keep him inside
because once he comes out he loses
control i go back to prison and i start
the whole thing over again and i'm
almost 50 years old and do i feel it
at times at times i feel it but
the most i can share with everybody is
if you've got something set in motion
and you're going to be somebody go ahead
and be somebody because there's certain
people that you meet in life like myself
that weren't given that option to become
who they wanted to become
they became somebody who other people
wanted them to become you know meaning
i wasn't given that option it wasn't
like i was told here you know you could
choose all this
no it was here this is what you got it
wasn't this is what you could choose it
was this is what you got live with it
take it that's it you know and then i
[ __ ] drugged my little brother along
for the ride and he didn't get the
option either because he had to follow
my footsteps and i followed him my
cousin's footsteps he followed my neck
because of my uncle we all went
down you know meaning was already set
you know he'd drop his clothes to him
and he'll wear his clothes and he would
sit down well they tried okay we'll go
buy this but it didn't work because soon
as we bought this put it on as soon as
we got home
took it off and put the other [ __ ] on so
you know if they made us wear it to
school we'd walk two blocks
throw a [ __ ] away put some other [ __ ] on
and go to school you know so
we weren't given the opportunity to
become the person we wanted to become
i'll keep myself in the ass because
i respect myself for who i am i'm
comfortable in my own skin but a lot of
times i envy the person that can walk
through a crowd without being noticed i
envy that person because i can't do that
and who i go i'm noticed i don't know if
it's the way i walk the way i talk to
where i act the way i look i don't know
but i envy the man who can walk through
a crowd and not be noticed i wish i
could be that man for one day just to
feel
how
it would be to be someone else because i
know who i am you know i mean i i i
always say that i don't look over my
shoulder lately i've been looking over
my shoulder and i don't know why but
lately i'd be looking over my shoulder
you know it's just a feeling i have but
i never looked behind me but lately i
have been looking behind me because [ __ ]
gets thick sometimes you know people get
upset jealous haters are a [ __ ]
and
they will mix you a lot a lot
even what you don't want but this is the
hand i've chosen this is the hand i was
dealt
all i can do is fold it i'll never
[ __ ] put my gloves up never i'll fold
my hand and i want to deal me another
one you know what i mean deal me another
one because every time i get a hand and
i go to play it it cost me a whole lot
cost me years in prison cost me my wife
my kids so all i do is i fold my hand
tell me another hand you know and they
deal me in their hands sometimes the
hand looks good and i'll bet on it
sometimes i'll lose sometimes i'll win
but
again i leave you with
if you got the opportunity to be
somebody else
you don't want to be mean you don't want
to be this person you don't want these
attributes in this life to
you have to deal with in the long run i
mean i'm almost 50 years old and still i
watch [ __ ] because i don't know
what he's thinking or what i did in the
past that might come and haunt me you
know it's a [ __ ] you know
but that's what i got for you today mark
huh all right mark i got a gang of a man
all kinds of different ones man
i just got you know what i mean in my
head mark you know you're always
interested i i've got all kinds of mark
man i just gotta go to my head
you